hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast advances in AMPK an otaku G
signalling I am Brenda Kelly Kim of
labyrinth and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's webcast is
presented by lab routes comm the leading
social media site for science
professionals and sponsored by cell
signaling technology cell signaling
technology is a private family-owned
company headquartered in Danvers
Massachusetts with over 400 employees
worldwide active in the field of Applied
systems biology research particularly as
it relates to cancer CST understands the
importance of using antibodies with high
levels of specificity and lot to lot
consistency it's why we produce all of
our antibodies in-house and perform
painstaking validations from multiple
applications and the same CST scientists
who produce our antibodies also provide
technical technical support for
customers helping them design
experiments troubleshoot and achieve
reliable results see more at wwl signal
calm before we start there are a few
instructions we want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment
answers are welcome to you can do this
by hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if we don't
have time today you want a better look
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you can't hear this presentation
properly or see it let us know by
clicking on the support button on the
top right or use the Q&A button and
we'll try to make sure to resolve any
issues please note this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the C e button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits now
let's get right to today's presenter we
are proud to welcome dr. Rueben Shaw dr.
Reuben Shaw is a professor in the
molecular and cellular biology
laboratory at the soft Institute
dr. Shahs lab focuses on the ampk
signaling pathway which coordinates
metabolism and growth at the cellular
and organismal level levels o'clock
across eukaryotes this pathway is
inactivated in a number of human cancers
and altered in metabolic disease the
Shaw lab has been using a combination of
biochemistry cell biology and
genetically engineered mouse models of
cancer to dissect the role of the lkb I
am Pete a tumor suppressor pathway in
coordinating metabolism Matassa G and
cell growth this work has led to the
identification of a number of new direct
substrates of AM Kincaid which provide a
molecular basis for how cells reprogram
their metabolism and growth under
conditions of nutrient deficiency the
Shaw lab also utilizes genetically
engineered mouse models to explore how
reprogramming of glucose and lipid
metabolism contributes to tumor Genesis
and to develop and test novel
therapeutic approaches from multiple
types of cancer
I'll now turn it over to dr. Rueben Shaw
for his presentation
great all right welcome everybody so I'm
going to talk to all of you today about
the center focus of my laboratory and a
metabolic pathway that actually links
the both acute and long-term effects of
metabolism to growth control and
therefore links different diseases
ranging from cancer to diabetes so the
central focus of my lab centers around
those two very basic cellular processes
how is cell metabolism and cell growth
coordinated at the molecular level and
out of our studies as we decode new
components of the signal transduction
pathways that modulate these we're
always looking for new avenues and new
targets to treat both cancer and
metabolic disease because as you're
about to hear in this case this
particular signaling pathway is altered
in both of these very distinct clinical
diseases so the focus point of my labs
work and the focus point of much of
today's talk starts with this very basic
signaling diagram that you can see on
this slide here and this involves a
highly conserved heterotrimeric protein
kinase complex known as the a MP
activated protein kinase which you see
here in the center of your slide across
all eukaryotic species as you can see at
the bottom of the slide
so from budding yeast all the way back
through plants flies worms and mammals
there is a ortholog of AMPK and its
associated subunits and in all of those
species they dictate different features
of metabolism so both glucose and lipid
metabolism how cells uptake glucose and
lipid and utilize it in store from
single-celled organisms all the way
through specialized metabolic tissues
and mammals all of them
engage this same pathway so it was some
years ago now when I was a postdoctoral
fellow and can't lease either medical
school working on not a metabolism gene
but in fact working on a kinase altered
in cancer that I made the unexpected
finding that that kinase lkb1 was in
fact the long sought after upstream
kinase that directly phosphorylates AMPK
and is required for its activation now
what was well appreciated in the field
was that this critical phosphorylation
event is stimulated under conditions
when cellular ATP levels are low so in
mammals this occurs under conditions of
low nutrients including hypoxia so low
oxygen or low glucose it also occurs in
response to a wide variety of
mitochondrial insults so anything that
inhibits ox fox a electron chance
electron transport chain inhibitors
including classic drugs such as an
Timaeus in' wrote known CCP anything you
don't even have to have full uncoupling
in the mitochondria even mild insults to
the electron transport chain will
decrease ATP output and therefore
decrease intracellular ATP levels
resulting in the activation of this
kinase cascade so under those conditions
lkb1
directly phosphorylates and turns on
ampk however in higher species such as
mammals this is not only activated in
the cell a thymus way by nutrients or
meta Kandra insults but hormones induced
in response to exercise as well as
caloric restriction also serve to
activate this two kinase cascade one of
the reasons there's been great interest
in ampk over the course of the past 15
years actually came from studies first
demonstrating that the widely used type
2 diabetes drug metformin in fact acts
as a complex one inhibitor
complex one of the Ox Foss chain is
actually inhibited by metformin and
related compounds this decreases ATP
output and while the details and the
relative importance of different
downstream effectors are still under
very active investigation by many labs
what is clear is that in all systems
metformin and related compounds robustly
activate AMPK and that plays at least a
partial role in mediating the benefits
of lower glucose and lower lipid in
response to metformin
besides metformin and related compounds
there are other ways to activate this
circuit pharmacologically there is a
cell permeable EMP mimetic known as AI
car which you can see on your left hand
side again that will directly bind to
this ampk heterotrimeric kinase complex
favoring its phosphorylation then by
lkb1
if you inhibit glycolysis in tumors or
in cell types that really rely on clike
pulses for their ATP production
it'll also activate this circuit and
then finally over the course of the past
decade a number of different
pharmaceutical companies first starting
with Abbott Laboratories in their
compound a seven six nine six six two
there are a number of different
derivatives of this compound and other
naturally even occurring compounds such
as salicylate that directly bind to
actually an interface of the beta
isoform of an PK and activate this
kinase complex independently of
intracellular ATP levels so there are a
number of different tools then that the
field uses to explore the relative
benefits and downstream effects of
activation of ampk itself this circuit
as I said gets activated under
conditions when intracellular ATP levels
are low and you can really think about
this as a checkpoint so many of you may
be familiar with the DNA damage
checkpoint that is activated when cells
receive damage to the
DNA kinases checkpoint kinases in that
case get activated and then they
phosphorylate a number of downstream
targets to help repair the DNA install
the cell cycle while they do so in this
case the insult to the cell is loss of
intracellular ATP and so under those
conditions AMPK is activated in lkb1
dependent manner and ap Caid wants to
immediately rapidly shut off ATP
consuming anabolic processes so all the
major biosynthetic causes these protein
synthesis lipid synthesis gets shut off
but it's not enough to stop the bleeding
of ATP from the cell you need to
actually restore ATP levels back to
normal and in some of the ways that ampk
does so is through the simulation of
fatty acid oxidation and as you'll hear
a lot about in today's talk through the
stimulation of a cellular process known
as our topic
now genetic and pharmacological studies
from a number of labs including my own
lab and our collaborators and the
studies that are highlighted in blue
here have gone on to study the role of
NPK in different specialized metabolic
tissues in mammals so in both knockout
genetic manipulation studies and mice
are pharmacologic studies and mice and
in lower species we and others have
shown the activation of ampk improves
blood glucose and improves lipid
contents in the liver and conversely if
you genetically remove an PK or its
upstream kinase you get hyper
glycemia if you remove the upstream
kinase and hyperlipidemia has been
observed by other laboratories Congress
Lee if you gain a am PK activity
pharmacologically you can stimulate
exercise and this is shown in a
collaboration between my lab and Ron
Evans lab you can extend the lifespan
the round worm C elegans and that was
work between my lab and indeed Dawn's
lab here at the salt and ampk has been
hypothesized and shown in a number of
studies a limited number but some very
nice studies to extend the longevity in
flies and to me the different
of caloric restriction and actually in a
wide variety of species so that's
another very active area of research
which is really the subject of a whole
different intense talk finally because
in mammals much of our nutrient sensing
capacity actually relies within
different neuron populations of our
brain others have studied the role of a
NPK in glucose sensing neurons and in
other neuronal functions where it also
plays critical roles finally if any of
you are listening and hoping to find out
more about new super enhancing drugs it
turns out that people abusing and piqué
activators are commonly found amongst
professional athletes as improving your
metabolism of course is one way to
improve athletic features and in fact at
both the Tour de France and other
sporting events in Europe various
coaches and players have been arrested
and tested positive for literally
carrying some of these compounds that I
alluded to which are bought from
standard chemical houses so it's quite
remarkable that not only our researchers
in this field working on new
therapeutics for diabetes and cancer
they're also accidentally discovering
the latest new drugs for doping finally
given the initial connection from my and
other work of cancer to this central
metabolic enzyme this raises the
question of whether or not other drugs
such as metformin or icar when taken by
diabetes patients or by other patients
whether or not this suppresses one's
risk of cancer and that is another very
active area of research which I won't
have time to talk about today but if
you're interested I encourage you to
check that out there are more and more
better detailed epidemiology and now
clinical trial studies of metformin in
different subtypes of cancer and the
wrong story short is that it appears as
is true for nearly all types of cancer
and their treatment to certain subtypes
may be gained benefit and men
types of cancer wills see no benefit at
all okay so given that seemingly almost
incredible list of benefits that are
gained from the activation of this
protein kinase there has also been
interested in interest and figuring out
which first of all how on earth does one
enzyme mediate these very disparate
seeming phenotypes from fighting aging
suppressing cancer suppressing diabetes
is this all through a handful of
specific pathways or are there different
subsets of downstream targets that
mediate different effects and this is in
fact the major focus of my laboratory so
using some of those genetic models that
I alluded to in mice we have set out to
dissect what the key direct substrates
the proteins directly phosphorylated by
an PK in different cells in different
tissues are and so one reason to do that
is not simply to identify new
therapeutic targets but beyond that even
developing a better toolset to be able
to track the activity of this pathway in
response to existing therapies and in
response to different disease states is
really critical for developing a more
detailed understanding of how cells
adapt their metabolism and adapt their
growth in response to different
physiological and pathological disease
changes okay so one of the central
techniques in central pursuits of my lab
has really been using a combination of
phosphoryl proteomics and bioinformatics
to identify new direct substrates of an
PK and without getting into the fine
details we used a peptide library
positional scanning methodology
developed by a professor named Ben Turk
at Yale University when he was also a
postdoc and Lewis can't lease I have a
hard medical school this method allows
you to get to use degenerate peptide
libraries to identify the optimal
sequence that a given kinase likes to
phosphorylate in this case NPK is a very
selective kinase and requires four or
five different specific residues
relative to a central phospho cerium
site that is targeted in order for
something to serve as named pick a
substrate in vivo as you might imagine
every time you start restricting and
imposing that has to be particular amino
acids relative to the serine that means
the number of proteins in the database
that contains such a sequence is more
and more restricted however I should
point out that if you look within the
human genome and ask how many proteins
contain this so-called optimal AMPK
motif the answer is around 2,000
proteins contain this sequence if he
then started cloning them one by one and
asked how many of them actually served
as a in PK substrates in vivo in cells
or in tissues and mice the answer is
less than a tenth so the presence of the
sequence appears to be required but it
by itself does not it's not sufficient
to tell you what is an imprecation
substrate and what is not in the in case
of straight so in the first part of the
screening method we use bioinformatics
to kind of generate that list of 2,000
prospects but the real area where we hit
paydirt was using biochemical
fractionation taking wild-type and
genetically knocked out ampk deficient
cells or implicated approaching tissues
or lkb1 wild-type or deficient cells or
deficient tissues we also have the extra
benefit that we know that this pathway
is activated only ends of response to
metabolic stress so as shown in this
example in actual mouse livers we can
treat mice with the diabetes drug
metformin which induces ATP loss within
the liver and then we can use an
affinity tool such as this phospho motif
antibody such as cell signaling cells in
fact for the AMPK substrate sequence
shown up top here and you can actually
immunoprecipitate proteins out of a
total cell lysate that bind to this
antibody
and so you can see only in response to
an energetic stress you get particular
polypeptides shown here by the red
arrows and you only see those in
wild-type livers treated with metformin
and not in the knockout livers treated
with metformin
another tool that we've used is taking
advantage of a natural phospho peptide
binding protein known as the fourteenth
III family of regulators 1433 proteins
only bind to phospho serums that
actually also have an overlapping
consensus with NPK you need to have a
base of fill like you have to have an
arginine or lysine in the -3 residue and
so that overlap between what 1433 likes
and what am PK likes means that we can
actually pass lysate over a column of
GST as compared to GST 14 through 3 and
ask out of a wild-type liver for example
what binds to 14 3 3 as compared to what
binds to 14 through 3 out of a name
became knockout liver and much of that
work is not yet published and so I won't
be talking about that today but we've
done that even using stable isotope ik
labeling in mammals with John Yates lab
at the script Research Institute up the
street but to summarize really the first
10 years of work out of the laboratory
we've decoded a handful of new direct
substrates of ampk that we believe are
critical for in decays ability to
regulate different aspects of cell
growth and cell metabolism so amongst
them we've identified phosphorylation
sites and the two worst grossest - TSE -
- a suppressor gene as well as the
protein wrapped or which is a direct
binding partner of the mammalian target
of rapamycin and these two events a
couple ampk activation - the inhibition
of mTOR activity so this is now very
well established from many labs and
actually from
a species across all of those eukaryotic
species starting with budding yeast an
ant PK ortholog inhibits mTOR function
across all of those species and there
was actually a very nice paper in Elife
just recently demonstrating in budding
yeast that the raptor homologue is in
fact directly targeted by the m2k
homologue sniff one so i would encourage
you to check that paper out if you're
interested in that evolutionary
conserved link in a sense this is one of
the most basic ways that all eukaryotic
cells know whether they have food or not
if you have food then inventory activity
is on themselves are allowed to grow if
you are low on nutrients at version and
ortholog of NPK gets activated it
directly phosphorylates a raptor
homologue a core component of mTOR and
immediately shuts off the central engine
of all cell growth we also have gone on
to show that other direct effectors of
mTOR including s orbital and
transcription factor are phosphorylated
by ampk on distinct sites and one of our
more recent discoveries in that area
which will now become the focus of the
rest of the talk is actually in a kinase
that in budding yeast is known as ATG
one otology one and in higher eukaryotes
is known as ulq one so otology is a
highly conserved cell biological process
that occurs basically in many different
cell types within the body and it is a
mechanism for the cell to clear both
protein aggregates as well as
dysfunctional organelles so outside of
the classic proteasome that targets many
proteins for degradation this is the
other major cellular disposal
destruction mechanism which is this
classic atop the g pathway the proteins
involved in autopsy were originally
worked out in genetic screens in budding
yeast and they were all given the suffix
80
gee so as I was just telling you the
very first gene and the most upstream
gene in the complex interesting Lee was
called HCG 1 and you can see in this
picture that I have at the top of the
slide this is taken from mammals so
there it's called ulk one
and what's more notable is actually that
this you locate one is actually the only
core component of the autopsy pathway
there is a Syrian threonine kinase so
all of the other components of the
canonical autopsy pathway including
different types of scaffolds or lipid
conjugating enzymes or variants in fact
of the classic ubiquitination cascade
and e2 s and E threes but lying at the
head of the pathway the gatekeeper
decision in fact funnels through this
serine threonine kinase known as ATG one
or ulk one and so it was there for a
great interest in my lab many years ago
now and one of the first graduate
students Daniel Egan identified unbiased
I identified you okay one as one of the
most highly regulated 14 through 3
binding proteins induced in response to
an PK and we believe that it was one of
the most differential hits because in
fact ampk phosphorylates at least four
different residues within you okay one
you okay one has a kinase domain and
it's in terminus and it has a conserved
c terminus by which is scaffolds two
other regulatory subunits in the middle
is this kind of disordered linker region
and that is where AMPA gate induces the
phosphorylation of you okay one on
highly conserved and PKA phosphorylation
sites in Sayulita two we map these sites
and all this data that I'm showing on
this point is actually published in the
supplement of that science paper that
was on the previous slide in the bottom
left-hand corner so I encourage you to
look it up if I'm talking too fast
and you're interested in these details
so it contained within the data back
paper are the four different a.m. PKA
phosphorylation sites that identified
two of which are well conserved in
okay one homologue known is you okay -
and both conserved at least back through
upper eukaryotes one of them has a
perfect both ampk phosphorylation site
and a perfect 14:33 binding site and
that is this Syrian 555 - which we
generate a phosphorus specific antibody
in collaboration with cell signaling
technologies and this antibody is now
commercially available and widely used
by the field so this is a great readout
of whether imprecate is talking to the
ecology complex so back at the time of
that study we did some old-fashioned
classic biochemistry and proved that
recombinant NPK will directly
phosphorylate you okay one and a test
tube using classic P 32 in future kinase
assays and for example and you can
compare the stoichiometry of that
phosphorylation to how well aimed became
phosphorylated wraptor a well studied
substrate raptor has two ampk
phosphorylation sites and you can see if
you actually look at the protein
abundance here judged by the mick tag in
the left hand bottom that actually you
okay one is much more highly
phosphorylated than raptor is in vitro
as I said in collaboration with cell
signaling we raised antibodies against
these sites in you okay one there's that
Syrian five five five antibody there's
also a Syrian four six one antibody and
you can see that were common ant BK and
in vitro induces you okay on
phosphorylation on those sites more
importantly we proved that we can use
such antibodies to read out the
activation of you okay one by AMPK
endogenously in different cell lysates
so in the upper left hand side here you
can see looking in hepatocyte s-- that
are wild-type or new okay one knockout
we can see the induction of endogenous
you okay one phosphorylation here in
response to metformin
so the widely used diabetes drug
metformin is actually inducing the
phosphorylation of you okay one within
an hour of treatment and one prediction
or question that raises then is for the
25 million type 2 diabetics to take
metformin every day whether anyone
realizes that or not they are at the
time they take the metformin pill
activating AMPK and activating you okay
one to initiate otology so you're
effectively activating otology in a
synchronized fashion in response to
metformin through this action now how
much toffee actually gets induced and
the relative importance of that ecology
is not known and that's something that
my lab is exploring right now but it's
still a very interesting thing to think
about the pharmacology of this and that
you could be synchronously activating a
tappa gene and that may have benefits on
the liver and on various physiological
functions so again on the right-hand
side of that same upper left panel
taking a NPK wild-type or knockout
hepatocyte again we see robust
phosphorylation of new okay one on that
Syrian site in response to metformin in
the past sites we see the same thing if
we lucky and mirroring embryonic
fibroblast so it Maps again you'll k1 or
AMPK wild-type or knockout when you see
robust phosphorylation of endogenous you
okay one now one of the biological
phenotypes of being deficient in otology
or deficient in a McCadden is actually
the accumulation distended and defective
mitochondria which does get worse over
time as you might expect
so when animals are first born the
number of defective mitochondria is
minimal but as one just lives their
lives you accumulate damage from a wide
variety of sources and that in fact
leads to the accumulation of defective
mitochondria which you can see if you
examine the paper closely in a final
point that's contained in that old paper
we showed that actually you require
those same PKA phosphorylation sites for
the function so eight new okay one
deficient cells that have been stained
reconstituted with a non phosphorylate
Abel Leoville Kieran is compared to
wild-type you okay one or a kinase an
active version of you okay one the
wild-type you okay one restores proper
mitochondria to these cells where's the
kinase dead the catalytically debianchi
one or even the catalytically active
version but a version that cannot be
signaled to by ampk that actually is
completely defective for proper
mitochondrial homeostasis and we looked
at this using other assays here we used
light a tracker to actually visualize
the mitochondria you can use a dye known
as JC one to look at membrane
mitochondrial membrane activity and
again we see that you require you okay
one and you require the am PK sites in
the okay one for proper mitochondrial
function a long-term biological
consequence of that is that cells that
are genetically deprived of core ottawa
g proteins either new okay one in the
okay to or a canonical component of the
pathway further down called ATG five if
you put them under starvation conditions
it's been reported by many labs
including Craig Thompson's labs one of
the first large papers on this topic
that actually cells that cannot undergo
otology cannot cannibalize their own
internal stores for nutrients more
rapidly undergo cell death
so what tava G is generally a cell
survival signal that allows cells to
live under nutrient limited conditions
and if you genetically remove etapa G
through removal of a gg5 or removal
you'll k1 or your Q on annual k2 you
simply increase apoptosis as read out
here through an exome five staining in a
fax assay a fluorescent activated cell
sorting type of assay importantly we
went on to reconstitute you okay one
deficient cells with again a wild type
or kinase dead or non phosphorylate a
boldly okey okey one
and we see very comparable effects
twofold efficiency in other words
wild-type you'll okay one restores
normal cell survival on to the you'll be
one deficient cells but the kinase dead
or the non phosphorylate able you'll
Kieran are equally defective and cannot
rescue cell survival in response to
starvation so the conclusion of all of
that is that mutation of the m2k sites
mule k1
mimics complete deficiency for you lucky
one so you need you okay one at least
for starvation to induce an PK to induce
self survival
so to give some big picture context of
this then actually within a peak a field
that was already known the AMPK in Laura
nutrient conditions can actually trigger
the formation of new mitochondria so
mitochondrial biogenesis which is
controlled transcriptionally that was
known to be under the control of an APK
already so with this study we showed
that the turnover of defective
mitochondria is under the control of a
NPK through its stimulation of you okay
one so we thought of this is kind of a
mitochondrial cash for clunkers program
where the cell trades in its defective
cars its defective mitochondria for a
shiny new mitochondria through the same
upstream signal from ampk another very
interesting and important point about
you okay one activity though is not only
is you okay one directly phosphorylated
and activated on those sites by a and B
K but on different sites of the new P 1
it is directly phosphorylated and
inhibited by an mTOR so you okay one
then sits as a downstream node that
integrates signals from both ampk and
mTOR and this fits well with decades of
studies of conditions that activate on
top of G is you can imagine when
nutrients are low am PK gets activated
it both directly stimulates ontology but
by AMPK phosphorylating tour it also
leaves this break that also gate keeps
you okay one activity so it's really in
a two-pronged mechanism that AMPK is
stimulating you okay one function both
bike directly phosphorylating it and
also by decreasing the amount that you
okay one is phosphorylated by indoor so
critical questions in the field back at
the time when we finish up that work or
whether or not you okay one itself would
turn out to be a critical inhibitor of
tumor Genesis or inhibitor of diabetes
in the same way that a NPK is thought to
be but then more directly what is you
okay one phosphorylating to cause its
effects and if we could make a drug that
inhibited you okay one function might
that have utility within cancer so as I
told you on top adji is a cell survival
mechanism in general in response to
stress and in particular response to
nutrient stress this was originally
defined actually an original papers from
the ocean lab here with hg1 deficiency
you can see if he starves them with
nitrogen the cells lacking HCG one
function completely crash within days so
wild-type cells deal with this stress in
part by inducing on top of G and I just
showed you our own data from a number of
years ago now that actually doing RNA I
against the only one you okay to you get
the same effect
now tumors it turns out also are
metabolically restricted for nutrients
including oxygen as well as glucose and
they rely on otology for a cell survival
and so now genetic studies mostly from
Eileen Eileen White's lab as well as
from Alec Hamilton slab genetically
targeted the autopsy process I should
also add Kevin Ryan's Latin Scotland's
and very nice work in this area and
shown that if you genetically remove
ontology you get defects in different
tumor formations in this summary taken
from a review article from Eileen
White's group and so I'll just direct
you if you're interested to check out
more about that but her lab in a series
of
over the past five years has shown that
combining genetic deficiency for the
critical the central atop of Eugene a
two g7 if you combine that in care ass
or b-raf Newton tumors either in the
lung or in melanomas and different
settings that you actually convert
aggressive carcinomas into more benign
arco saitama's is the clinical
pathological term for these more benign
tumors which also have as a cardinal
feature defective mitochondrial function
so this suggests that perhaps inhibiting
otology function would be beneficial for
the treatment of cancer and in
particularly the Kimmelman lab out of
Harvard Medical School has shown that
this is particularly at play in the
context of pancreatic cancer and again
I'll just suggest you check out papers
from that lab beyond that though this
same circuitry of mTOR regulating you
okay one will get engaged in a response
to a wide variety of anti-cancer agents
so not only mTOR inhibitors themselves
but also inhibitors of upstream inputs
to mTOR including a KT pi3 kinase or EGF
receptor inhibitors all of them will
result in a suppression of mTOR
catalytic activity because mTOR inhibits
you'll kill one activity when you
inhibit endure or inhibit any of these
upstream inputs you will dramatically
and rapidly increase your k1 activity
and ontology that implies that all
cancers that are being treated with
targeted therapeutics of the kind that I
list on the right-hand side will have at
least an immediate response of the
induction of autophagy via you okay one
that is a testable hypothesis which has
not been fully tested in fact
that comes out of this simple chemical
circuitry so with that in mind my lab
and collaboration with others was
interested in whether or not if one
developed a competitive inhibitor
of you okay one you would then lose the
survival benefit the tumor cells gain
when you treat with these cells it's
known that many of these drugs are in
fact site of static and therefore if you
can convert their responses to a more
cytotoxic response that would be a great
benefit for cancer to therapy now I
should add that on top of G is very
common mechanism there are many studies
now this is taken from a review article
from cell death and differentiation
last year listed at the bottom so I
would urge you to check that out if
you're interested
but etapa G is a common mechanism now
documented in response to many different
anti-cancer agents as I just suggested
on the previous slide they are now have
now been documented they and many other
styles of cancer therapies have been
documented to induce etapa G in response
to that fact many have been keen on
drugging otology for cancer therapy and
as such the only pre-existing compounds
that inhibit on top of G are lysosome
atrophic agents such as the chloroquine
family of compounds so these are
lysosome inhibitors and therefore you're
not selectively inhibiting a tappa G
you're actually inhibiting all lysosomal
function incredibly that's actually
tolerated in cells and in the body and
you can actually have therapeutic
benefits from these agents and that is
as you can tell these are clinical
trials and different types of cancer
where chloroquine and chloroquine
derivatives are being engaged and again
here's the reference to this review
article that talks about all these
different clinical trials were
chloroquine drugs being try now to come
back to where I was many slides ago
you'll kill one as I said is the only
serine threonine kinase though so that
means it is
the only readily druggable targets
within this complex there are other
proteins particularly within the victim
conjugating system that are also in
theory druggable and there is great
interest in all of these as well as this
lipid kinase VPS 34 in the middle which
is also in theory druggable however a
VPS 34 also plays central roles and
vesicular trafficking outside of its
roles and on top of G so it's really
important to try to find targets that
are dedicated for otology and also for
the cancer context you would only be
treating patients for a short amount of
time and therefore you would not have
the side effects and negative
consequences of prolonged inhibition of
ontology okay
so as I told you you look you want helps
promote cell survival by keeping cells
alive under stress so how do we go about
developing a therapeutic well we use
those same peptide library screening
methods that I told you about for NPK
and I won't go through them now this was
recently published we did the same thing
for you look you won turns out you will
q1 is also very selective kinase not
quite as selective as NPK but
interestingly and oddly requires
hydrophobic residues in the minus 3
position you can see my thiamine is
highly selected for in these peptide
libraries and to make a very long story
short we recently published the results
of this screening methods and identified
a number of different Newell k1 in vivo
phosphorylation sites in other core
otology proteins we have not explored
the functional effects of all of these
different phosphorylation events and in
fact we focused on one this one
particular serine within VPS 34 which is
quite well conserved and interestingly
it appears to be the only you will kill
on phosphorylation site MVPs 34 what's
also notable is that cooling wands lab
also working on you loci one identified
a phosphorylation site in the VPS 34
binding partner beckylyn serine 15 we
also in apparently identified that site
and what's most striking is that the
sequence of beckylyn
I think it's phosphorylated by you okay
one in their study also aligns well with
the sequence flanking VPS 34 so we think
there is a you okay one motif so to
speak at least a loose motif and that is
in common between these two substrates
interestingly those two targets then are
the very first to have commercial
phospho specific antibodies generated
against them a number of companies have
made antibodies against the Beck incite
cell signaling cells a nice antibody
against this beckons hearing 15
phosphorylation site they also sell an
antibody that we developed in
collaboration with them against the
syrian 249 site in VPS 34 I'm going to
keep talking about that site for the
remainder of the talk but so if you are
interested in blotting for you okay one
activity in your system these two
antibodies phospho stirring 249 and PPS
10 before inserting 15 and beckylyn are
some of the more advanced reagents that
exist collaborating with nick Cosford
slab nick is a professor at the Sanford
Berman premise medical Discovery
Institute down the road here in La Jolla
California Nick's lab or gurus and
medicinal chemistry and so taking ATP
competitive inhibitors we see really
examined and identify tool compounds
that directly inhibit Newell k1 and I
won't belabor this since I'm short on
time and this is all published now but
we scream through hundreds of different
compounds to identify a lead tool
compound which we published in this
paper earlier this summer this compound
SBI Oh 206 965 which I will refer to for
the rest of the talk simply as six nine
six five shows quite incredible
selectivity for you okay one when that
was one of the reasons that we focused
on this particular compound we had other
compounds that also very nicely in heavy
dual q1 being having a number of other
cases this compound was very selective
towards Newell k1 and I would just urge
you to explore the paper for more of the
data such as this screening method from
discover rx that we use to actually
examine the true specificity so indeed
we profiled all 500 512 kinase --is in
terms of their selective binding in mule
k1 indeed is a very selective inhibitor
this is a very selective inhibitor for
you okay one the selectivity in fact is
so great that if you compare it to other
ATP competitive kinase inhibitors in the
clinic 6065 itself even as a tool
compound is very favorable and has a
profile very similar to different EGF
receptor and BCR Abel ATP competitive
inhibitors which are in the clinic right
now and it's even better than other ATP
competitive inhibitors which are also
widely used in the clinic so it's the
type of compound one could use at least
in theory we went on to use RNA i to
prove that some of the other kinase is
such as fact which is one of the other
major kinase is that it independently
inhibits that fact is not regulating on
top of gene in any of the systems that
we're looking at and so again we believe
that you okay one is a key target for
some of the effects of this compound
here we are just showing that the
compound when treated in cells that are
over expressing you okay one that you
can actually suppress that
phosphorylation events I told you about
a few slides ago the site and VPS 34 or
the site in Becklund the phosphorylation
of those is diminished when you treat
cells with this 6 9 6 5 compound
another thing that's known about on top
of G is that not only will starvation do
citavi G but actually chemical in
ambition of mTOR itself will induce
autophagy here we're using this on top
of your site OID kit to read out top of
G within this particular cell type a 5 4
9 cells if you treat with a chemical
inhibitor of mTOR such as AZ da 0 5 5
you see the induction of these Auto
phagosome which are in fact blocked by 6
9 6 5 treatment finally is another read
out of you ok one activity in the cell
there is a phosphorylation site in the
you okay one complex component a 2 G 13
which can be read out here endogenously
it is increased in response to mTOR
catalytic inhibition and it is
suppressed in response to our 696 v
compound so this is the third phosphate
specific antibody that i've mentioned
today that serves as a readout of usual
k1 activity I won't belabor some of this
because we're running short on time and
I want to make sure that we have time to
get to questions but within the this
study who went on to show that treating
cells with this uo k 1 inhibitor
induces apoptosis only in the context of
starvation so if you treat most normal
cells with this compound this is they
completely tolerate it and happening on
top of G is fine if you have plenty of
nutrients around but if you put them
into starvation conditions then you
induce very potent apoptosis
as you can see here and you can see with
other readouts on the right-hand side
however tumor cells have which as I
mentioned earlier have higher rates of
basil on top of G than normal cells and
indeed in tumor cells as you can see in
this dose response curve just escalating
doses of 6 1965 by itself is sufficient
to induce cell death is read out by an X
in five staining so it at 5 and 10
micromolar 6 9 6 5 8 5 4 9 cells start
rapidly undergoing apoptosis and this
effect is increased dramatically
if you treat with the inter catalytic
competitor
indeed we head-to-head compared the
ability of three different inventory
drugs to synergize in their pop tonic
potential if we compare them with DMSO
or are you okay one inhibitor or
chloroquine and in every context
combining are you okay one inhibitor
with the inter catalytic inhibitors led
to the greatest amount of apoptosis so
the take-home messages for you okay one
inhibition that are that for tumors that
are reliant on emptor catalytic activity
so tumors that have mutations either
within the import pathway itself or the
pi3 kinase pathway treatment with
rapamycin analogs or other inter
inhibitors are starting to hit injure
the clinic and we believe that part of
the reason these drugs may be site
estatic is because when you put those
inhibitors on you actually induce
otology and you induce you okay one
activity as a cell survival mechanism
see if you combine rapa logs or other
import catalytic inhibitors with you
okay one inhibitors you will improve the
therapeutic response but this need not
be limited to mTOR inhibitors it may be
that actually treatment with a wide
variety of therapies induce Lata the
gene and therefore combining you okay
one inhibitor with many different types
of conventional and targeted cancer
therapies will emerge as a benefit
finally though we also know that there
are some subsets of tumors that are
truly appear to be addicted to ontology
and we in the field are learning more
and more about how to best define those
tumors and the patients that would be
benefited by this but in those cases you
okay one inhibition as a single agent
appears to be as effective as many other
treatments so that's another very active
area of exploration
so as my final slide now some ten years
later of investigation from many labs
has really developed a far more complete
picture
of what how am PK reprograms Cell
Metabolism
and therefore how wide variety of
natural insults to the cell and nutrient
deprivation reprograms metabolism so all
these phosphorylation sites shown on
this cartoon are all different things
that the field is developing reagents to
in different phospho specific antibodies
can help guide you towards whether or
not any of these things are important in
your favorite tissue or a disease date
of interest and as I said we focused a
lot today on the okay one finally I
would be remiss if I didn't show you a
picture of the lucky people in my lab
that I am very lucky to have worked for
me and who have done much the work that
we talked about today the newel k1
project was a cat inhibitor project was
a collaboration with Nick Cosford shown
here in his laboratory and
sanford-burnham just up the street here
a large number of people from his lab
helped out but some of those are just
highlighted here within my own lab the
key drivers of the ulk one work were Dan
Egan very talented PhD student in the
lab and Matthew Chun postdoc in my lab
who helped in here at the project from
Dan and then took it on into the
therapeutic avenues at this point I'd
like to thank you for listening to this
intense blast of science and that I'm
ready to answer questions thank you
excellent presentation dr. Schaack thank
you for bringing that information to us
before we get to the questions I just
want to remind our audience that they
can submit them through the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and we're gonna get
to as many as we can
our first question given that inhibition
of auto foggy auto CG as in a TG 7
knockouts with chloroquine can inhibit
tumor growth do you predict that you lk1
inhibitors can be used as standalone
therapeutic agents or do you think the
cytotoxic effect of these inhibitors
relies on the addition of itachi
inducers like mTOR inhibitors
okay great question let's see yes I'm on
a great question
I think I may have touched on this right
at the end and I think at least from the
data that the world has so far we and
other labs have so far we think there
are a subset of tumor types
perhaps pancreatic cancers based on how
the Kimmel men's work or tumors
containing beer a 4k resolutions where
your k1 inhibitors make sure the
greatest benefit as a single agent and
then for other more complex somatic
acquired tumors such as lung cancers or
colon cancers there you might want to
combine it best that that's the way that
will be used great thank you for
answering that our next question you
have shown that ampk inhibitors you have
shown that a pmk inhibitors I'm sorry
I've lost the question our next our next
question he jiong from University of
Nebraska asks what is upstream of lkb1
and how is lkb1 activated great question
great question the whole field has
actually been searching for answers to
that question for some time the thought
in the field right now is that lkd one I
should say the dog might write as many
is that
lkb1 is just active in the wide variety
of conditions normally so in issues and
certainly my own lab is seen in the
liver for example of mice without insult
lkb1 is active and as phosphorylating a
number of it's downstream targets
outside of AMPK so lkb1 phosphorylates
other targets
besides ampk and perhaps it's only under
conditions of low ATP that ampk gets
brought to lkb1 i think this that
question really is one of the biggest
ones in the lkb1 field that remains to
be answered we don't know we wonder
whether doubt they're phosphatases that
actually are stimulating the process to
begin with but whether or not there are
other kinase is upstream of lkb1 that is
not known frankly there's a number of
different candidates papers have looked
at it but there's no there's no direct
answers next question great our next
question at a given time in a cell that
grows in a nutrient replete conditions
could a significant fraction of ampk
still be active if so could this ampk
subset be sequestered in other protein
complexes for example you okay one yeah
that's another great question I think
that's another area the field is kind of
steering towards now or at least in my
own opinion people in the field are
steering towards is what are the
different pools of ampk within the cell
and are there some pools just as your
question is getting at the in fact maybe
active even when nutrients are there in
so that you always have some mixture of
AMPK being aligned and regulating some
subset of targets perhaps around the
mitochondria but then that other
populations are kept inactive and so I
would say the field does not know but I
think that is very plausible and I think
that's going to be a very interesting
area to watch and I hope many different
labs in many different systems actually
try to explore that and I think it's
very possible that you okay one AMPK and
tour itself at certain times are at
certain locations within the cell and
maybe that will come back in other
questions next question next question
great thank you would you consider
activation of Auto Fuji in early ampk
activity many studies don't see
activation of ampk until 24 to 48 hours
after metformin treatment do you suggest
that there are both early and late
stages of
ampk yeah but that's that's another
that's another really good question I do
think and there was precedent for a
published data for different waves of
ampk activation in some studies there
was very nice MCB paper from in 2007
specifically you could find it if you
looked up leptin do a PubMed search for
leptin and CTC 12 cells in that study
they were looking at a biphasic AMPK
response in response to leptin in that
cell type but they also explored
activation of different pools in fact of
ampk so that comes back to one the
earlier questions and again I think this
is really under exploring I should
finally add relating to your question
though I think one another limitation
within the field is that the tools to
study
ampk particularly in tissues both from
animals certainly in rare tissue
settings from human
Asians that antique actually gets
activated when you harvest tissues so
within frankly within seconds even
certainly within minutes of isolating a
tissue you get very robust EMP
activation in the tissues before you
flash freeze them so that has confounded
many different studies looking at am PK
activation after given drugs in our own
hands we can see am PK getting activated
in rodent liver within 30 minutes of
metformin treatment so I think a lot of
it is really being able to get the
background that is from harvesting
reduce to see those effects so we think
metformin very rapidly reduces NPK in
the body depending on the tissue you're
looking at and in hepatocyte for example
it activates a PK within 15 minutes in
primary appendicitis but your concept of
different waves of AMPK I think even
though it's not great data for it I'm
sure that's true
why don't we maybe we can try to get
some questions from you know trying to
get questions from different people
since we're running short on time let's
thank you our next question Josh asks
there is talk of AMPK being a
context-dependent
uncle gene is it promoting mythology and
established tumors if so why not develop
AMPK inhibitors that's another great
question and I think there is emerging
data there was actually a very nice
paper which I believe is just online in
the past couple of weeks and in fact
you'll see this in accompanying news and
views from that I wrote for this paper
in cell stem cell genetically proving
within a subtype of leukemias that AMPK
is in fact required for the growth of
those leukemias so this is one of the
first well-defined examples on the
context dependent on key genetic
activity what's even more remarkable
about that study is that ampk is only
having the function in certain tissue
sites so an apk is only active in those
cells when they're in the bone marrow
not in the spleen or in the blood in
other settings so it illustrates some of
the complexities that are going to be
involved in when am PK or you okay one
itself may be engaged physiologically to
keep tumor cells alive again
your concept though is valid that you
might want to develop you NPK inhibitors
I assume people are doing so and I think
the challenge there just like you look
at one inhibitors you only want to use
them in settings that are short you
don't want to incidentally give someone
a different disease just by treating
their cancer but I think there is the
prospect so good question
thank you for that answer our next
question from Samara can a peak ampk
activate Auto Sochi in the presence of
active MTO rc1 a good question that has
been explored mostly in cells of course
in the context of treating with
different doses of AMPK activators which
themselves lead to a decrease in mTOR I
think a different way to rephrase your
question within the cell at any given
time when you treat with either a
pharmacological drug to activate NPK or
under nutrient deprivation conditions
you will have individual amp UK
complexes floating around the cell that
are going around and shutting off mTOR
and going around in activating you okay
one so I think there is a battle at
different sites within individual cells
that are going on and the net output of
how much otology is induced I think that
is an open question however there are
examples at least just from studying
published reports where you have cell
conditions where a mpk appears to be
active as read out by some of its own
phosphorylation of phosphorylation of
its targets in tor is also active in the
same lysate at least but the dominant
effect is the suppression of etapa G so
either the relative activation tour is
just much higher even though you see
some ampk tor is winning the battle
within individual cells or you have
different within different populations
within the tissue or within different
cells and PK has won the battle and it's
and it's winning it you know it is
inhibiting on top of you within a subset
of the cells whereas in another subset
tor is high this is going to be
something that's going to take single
cell analysis to really answer but I
think with better tools to look at on
top of G
that will get there great our next
question from Naveen which tumors or
cell lines are the most dependent on
otology yeah that's a good question Fred
for that I would actually refer people
to published works probably the work of
Ella Kimmelman there was a genes and
development paper from his lab so ki mme
lvan that looked at this direct question
at least using chloroquine as a readout
of ontology inhibition and it's one of
the first figures of his paper but there
are other papers that have looked at
this my own lab has not really looked at
this that much in depth nor have we
fully some of the other questions later
on that we're not gonna have time for we
have not fully examined ourselves
massive cell line panels to actually ask
where our compound may work best as a
single agent so those are ongoing things
that the true settings where six nine
six five will be useful in different
subsets of cancer and in mice and all
those kinds of things those are all our
ongoing types of studies so I think in
in the interest of time let's just take
I think we really only have time for one
or two more questions if we can go to
question 18 here
I guess it's from the same individual
but that's another interesting question
great thank you
what type of nutrient deprivation do you
perform to induce atrocity in your
systems zero glucose or low glucose or
zero serum or low serum glutamine
limitation glutamine absence or some
combination
so so for this I would refer people to
that recent publication the molecular
cell paper from my lab Egon Chun at all
in most of the settings we used EBS s
media which is basically amino an amino
acid deficient media but it still has
glucose so but we can also get the same
effects by putting cells into no glucose
it just takes a longer amount of time so
the fastest way to induce you okay wanna
to induce otology in many people's hands
is either with EBS s media or HBS s
media in my own lab we use EBS s so
let's go to potentially a final question
question number two
great thank you have you looked at six
nine six five effects in cancer models
in vivo pancreatic cancer in particular
okay that's actually question twenty-two
but that's fine
I met question two but we'll just end
here on this note as I alluded to in my
answer to the previous question that is
something that we are actively looking
at right now so if any of you've seen me
at a meeting or someplace else ask me
that question again in six months and
we'll see where we're at but that's
something that multiple people in the
lab are actively pursuing thank you
great thank you so much I'm just trying
to find your last question too
you have shown that and AMPK inhibits
mTOR and that many targets such as ulk
one are regulated by the two kinases in
a yin-yang manner can mTOR directly
inhibit AMPK and how yep okay so I think
this is another interesting area for the
field the question is can import
directly
how does Emmitt or itself inhibit AMPK
if an PKA is going around the cell
trying to shut off mTOR is int or itself
trying to directly inhibit ampk so there
are no direct phosphorylation sites from
the Tor complex itself known within ampk
however there are reported essex
climbing sites within ampk in fact some
of the same sites that in other
conditions are thought to be
phosphorylated by a KT to inhibit amp
decay function and on that topic I would
refer you to a study from Barbra Kang's
lab in the journal Cell Metabolism
I think about two years ago now
reporting the s6 kinase 1 a direct
import target can directly phosphorylate
one of the two catalytic subunits so
with that thank you for all this great
interest and feedback this is the first
time I've ever done a webinar and I can
see this is a very exciting and
fantastic way to connect researchers
with the broader research audience so I
hope all of you enjoyed it and I think
there'll be a mechanism for further
feedback as well but I hope all of you
wherever you are all over the world have
a great rest of your day have a great
night
thank you
Thank You dr. Shah for bringing that
information to us
excellent presentation today I do want
to let our audience know that this
presentation will be available on-demand
through May of 2016
they're welcome to log in and look at it
again you'll be receiving an email from
labyrinths is when it's available and we
invite you to share that you know with
your colleagues I'd like to also thank
our sponsor cells signaling technology
for making it possible to bring this
information to you today thank you again
for joining us goodbye